ね名誉も海であ船めちゃめちゃ化しているうそ
遊歩取ったおいこんなは肇社長と
んだ
そういうやつ使う皆さんごっそ
と言いますでしょうか一時期すごいみたいな感じたんだこれパッケージきたな
ご覧くださいもうこの女の鼻毛がごっそり結構有名ですよねでもなんか一時期すごいは
すごいこれがあれば鼻毛が取れるみたいな高ちょっと巷でキャッキャしてたんですけど
この子ストっていうやつ何かと言いますと
月脳は
x でございますそれも鼻毛専用1行派の10回分だってレンジで全して解けたやつを
鼻にぶっさして現段狸御殿も取れるっていう奴なんですけどもやったことあるねこれ
なんか使った人何か見たことあるんですけども
すごい痛いらしくてみんな本当に痛そうなんですよそこまでして鼻毛抜くんだった花
外科
ただでジュリってやればいいんじゃないかということを持っててちょっとあの
不毛な
争いだと思ってるんですよ家だけに
というわけで僕ちょっと考えたんですけども人の痛覚が鈍っている瞬間って派ならず
あると思うんですよそれいつかというと寝てる時って普通に幸を着ているときに分
開ける時よりねっている時にぶん投げられた方が鳴っ
みたいな通過距離驚きの感情が前に出てくるのでボスとも同じ考え方をすると
僕が寝てる時にゴーストップチ込まれて
家と鼻呼びかけてもそんなに痛くないんじゃないかと思いますって画期的に痛くないの
に柱が全部抜けるって言うちょっと坊さんの新たな使い方になるのではないでしょうか
今回哲也足てってねさんの限界でさらにそこでお酒を入れてるんで今た秒でんでれると
思いますね僕が死んだように寝ている間にかね濁すを準備してもらって僕の端にぶっ
さして見てもらうと
思いますちょっと子様準備だけしておきましょう
もういいアマって凄い凄いチーク出すみたいなってこれを溶かすんだったのはここに
説明書が入っておりますで僕は2日分みようと思います
おやすみ3店をしてねます準備してる時には多分僕は何も聞こえないと思うんで
これでじゃあねていこうと
思いますでは任せたぞ
[音楽]
恋おやすみてるっちゃ
me
うんうん
不不不不不不不不不
うん
ん
あった
持っていた
[音楽]
ターン
ん
んだろ
あっはぁんっ
バッハ r 2
[音楽]
ん
ana
[音楽]
バッハ
ni
me
dea
re だった
立っ
持ってい
たち止めてえっっ
ハイパントに貼っ本体に入っ
2 el